let's talk about the best protein for
recovery
not just from exercise but from stress
from
being sick now you have two things you
have protein that is absorbed in the
body
okay and then you have protein that's
actually used
by the body two different things most
the protein is absorbed
but only a small portion is actually
utilized
and when i talk about used i'm talking
about in the repair action
and also providing the raw material to
build new proteins
your body makes about 50
000 proteins a day and what i'm talking
about is
proteins are different combinations of
amino acids
and you might be thinking protein only
as
muscle right but you have hair you have
nails
you have tendons ligaments fascia which
is the outer covering or connective
tissue around different things
you have cartilage you have your skin
dna
rna all the cellular machines inside the
cell
are made with proteins enzymes
are made with proteins both digestion
and in chemical pathways hormones are
made from proteins
what about lipoproteins like hdl or ldl
that's proteins that carries the
cholesterol
through the blood blood is protein and
your immune system
is protein so a lot of your body
is protein and so when you consume
dietary protein
only a portion of that protein is
utilized
by the body for this and this
the rest is either wasted through the
kidney
or used as fuel because it converts to
glucose
the way they measure how much protein is
being wasted or used for fuel versus use
is by the nitrogen in the urine and that
way you can tell
the utilization percentage
at the top of the list we have breast
milk of course this is not available to
most people unless you are an
infant but that's 49.6
so we're going to go with the egg okay
egg is number two
but out of most proteins this is pretty
high
you get a 49 utilization
so eggs are a really good protein to use
in recovery but check this out
let's say you're into bodybuilding and
you're taking all this whey protein
for recovery or you want to grow your
muscles look at this
it's only 17 compared to eggs which is
that means that you're only using 17 the
rest is waste
or fuel look at this soy protein
16 it's in a lot of
protein bars it's in a lot of diet
shakes
it's going to end up with a lot of
glucose right here and then look at this
branch chain amino acids
one percent utilization the rest is
either waste
or fuel you might be thinking oh i have
to take some branched chain amino acids
because
i need to repair my muscles well it
might be only benefiting you from the
fuel standpoint because
branched chain amino acids is not
complete
and any time you are trying to repair or
build muscle you need a complete protein
now there is one blend of essential
amino acids
that can give you a 99
utilization rate and only a one percent
waste
or a fuel it's called keto aminos i put
a link down below if you want more data
on that
but that's not actually a dietary
protein it would be more of a supplement
to assist
in the recovery process hey before you
go real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course
will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist your environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below check it out and get
signed up today